hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to deep you now in this
game we're gonna be playing domination
of which I have never played I've never
even started a game I've never explored
it this is completely a new territory
for me and it may be new territory for
some of you guys so okay so there's two
teams
there's some weird yellow boxes over
there I don't know what they do but they
do something so what is the thing that
they do cuz I don't know why are these
guys just standing here oh my god
are they the desecrated relics of the
pool of my former teammates I have no
idea so what are these yellow squares
ooh what is that
Oh what is that Oh what is that
well that's cool [ __ ] goddamn it I'm
getting too eager in the beginning of
the game oh [ __ ] but that's cool what is
that I want to know whoo okay oh jeez
alright I'm gonna go a different route
than I usually go let's see I want
sniper before I don't know if I want to
do that I've never done flank guard I've
never really done flank guard before so
I'm gonna try this a little bit it's
nice to have some reverse engineering
going on here so that I don't have to
worry about people sneaking up behind me
I gotta I'm I'm I'm by bifurcated
nevermind you know what I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna do that bad idea oh geez
he's got shoot shot well this is good
okay this this guy this changes up my
thinking because now I have to worry
about frickin which direction I'm going
in holy crap whoa whoa buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy but come come on come
on come on so what happens if we kill
these guys like obviously it looks like
we can only really whoa that is
dangerous holy [ __ ] I was not ready for
that okay so let's frickin do something
again all right flank guard bullet pen
good god I was not ready for that
so I imagine that we got to try to kill
these things and preferably get the last
hit on him I'm at
is what the wind condition is actually
gonna be ah [ __ ]
anybody gonna help me out with this it's
actually what we want to do or is this
why I'm glad it's on me nobody else I'm
helping the team right there's this
credit for this gonna happen right oh
[ __ ]
whoa hey the SE dominators now
controlled by the red what does that
mean I don't know what that means what
CSE Dominator whoa someone is coming in
hot heavy heavy oh that guy got owned uh
okay so I imagine that when you kill
that thing you're gonna get a thing to
compliment your thing body dammit [ __ ]
it in what body damage god dammit I
didn't [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] goddamn it I
almost died just from that man out I'd
hate to think that some people have pro
strats in this [ __ ] someone already
knows how to dominate a team from just
playing this stupid mode it's not stupid
just right now I have no idea what I'm
doing so because I'm stupid
this seems stupid the north all the
Northwest Dominator why did they go for
that Dominator Oh God
also those things are Dominator though
southeast Dominator is what I was saying
so I was just too too stupid to
understand what that man I don't know my
cardinal direction farewell oh [ __ ]
someone is someone is playing very
aggressively over here and I appreciate
it but I'd appreciated more fuels on my
goddamn team not their goddamn team
there we go northeast dominators now
controlled by the blue so I imagine you
win when you control all of these
quote-unquote dominators so when the
hell is that gonna happen
whoa hmm don't kill me bro okay actually
I'm gonna do twin flank I think that
yeah this is what I wanted
hell yeah man oh this way better oh this
way better oh yeah get him get him get
him buddy get him oh wow that was wow
they take some they take some patterns
oh I push them out of the way with my
bullets oh nice no it's nice nice ah
okay don't push them towards me god damn
it look up push up towards me that's
instant
that's instand death get him get him get
him guys you're welcome
you're welcome for this I'm helping I'm
helping whoa geez oh geez oh geez oh
geez oh geez orgies orgy uh oh pockets
are scary I just need to stop shooting
at them when they're coming my way
unless they actually are smart there we
go oh [ __ ] our teammates just got
blasted away okay here we go
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
get him yeah get him
no don't get too close no god this
doesn't seem good for us it seems bad
but our whole team is behind this Oh
this unity this is unity unlike any
other oh sorry for getting in your way
beaver
come get some
we got the whole mighty the blue Armada
on the world I'm scared I'm scared I'm
scared I'm scared I killed someone but
I'm scared someone's over here and
they're getting a lot of both we okay so
we gotta mmm
they're coming for this one I don't want
to let them have it I mean I'm gonna let
them have it but they're not gonna have
it is what I mean by that
oh it's twin on twin point on twin oh
[ __ ]
I'm not high enough level for this I
think I might go in this mode I think I
might actually go for the cannon ball
because the cannon ball
I killed help yay because the cannon
ball is extremely high damage and if I
can just get close then I can bash him
up a bit
wonder what our team is doing or they
just off on the sides trying to level up
where's my chat oh god oh that's good no
that's good they all went to though hmm
whoa triple Twinner octa tank
I like the idea of arcattack oh I spent
so fast I shoot in just a few directions
[ __ ] our tag if you control your
rotation you really do shoot in just a
few directions but it's good it's a good
it's bad for doing single target damage
like on this guy but it's good for other
things too northeast ah man they took
the Northeast back damn it yeah the
octave tank Akhter tank might have
definitely been a mistake I'm not a
hundred percent sure about this whoa
that's a lot of bullets in a very
specific direction where I got a lot of
bullets in a very general direction I'm
helping I'm helping kind of maybe not
really holy [ __ ] this is kind of bad
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
bags
Oh dick oh oh god I'm gonna die now holy
crap I shoved that little guy in the way
yeah I'm such a piece of [ __ ] but I'm
gonna survive oh god no I'm not
whoa what is that big guy what does
Killa I want to know what kill is he
seems like some sort of super sniper I
like that I like that yes yes I was part
of that he died but I was part of it
because I helped oh that's not good hey
I killed him yeah I killed him yeah I
got a lot of points for that 58 thousand
I'm probably on the leaderboard but
there isn't a leaderboard in this game
mode but that that removes one of their
one of their higher level players from
the roster which is good for us that
getting faster I don't like this I don't
like the sound of that yeah there we go
it's contested now be able to spin to
win it whoa that's not good I'm dead I'm
dead I'm done I didn't like that at all
I'm gonna try the twin again
yeah we got the Northeast one even
though I got [ __ ] up totally by
accident wasn't my fault at all you
caught me off guard on a bad day with my
all right triple shot quad tank twin
flank oh I guess I can go on different
upgrade paths well I don't really like
the triple shot but I'll take it yeah
I'm gonna go for the southeast one soon
I just I just need to level up yeah I
need to be like higher level or else
this isn't gonna work out for me that
guy's almost did almost max level almost
there almost there yeah we're getting
this thing we're getting it changing it
over okay we got this we got this we got
this whoa we're gonna win this we're
gonna win this baby we're gonna win it
we're gonna win it
I wish it would give you like mine you'd
score for hitting it but I guess that's
part of the strategy you either got to
hit it or you got to go farm up yeah we
got it
oh three four whew that's a lot of
bullets holy [ __ ]
but this is awesome I love this moment
this is good mode I said we just got to
go for the last one well it looks like
everyone's making a final push anyway I
wish I was just a little higher level
just a few more points just a few more
points it's not gonna be any nearby just
because it's so stocked up there's so
many people in this area oh I think
we're gonna get it I think we're gonna
get it we're gonna get it think we're
gonna get it we're gonna get it whoo
[ __ ] that's a lot of red bull [ __ ]
that's not gonna matter because we're
gonna good yeah look out Alan Alan whoa
geez Alan
Wow Alan Helen holy crap we got it we
got it we got it we got it we got it we
got it we got a little bit anyway so
that is the end of the game arena is
closed no players can join so it's just
a murder spree until the everyone
decides to leave but that is what this
game is who is shooting yellow bullets
what the hell was that oh my god oh my
god oh god is here oh god it's the arena
closer holy [ __ ] oh god they're so scary
but either way that is domination
game-mode I highly suggest you give it a
try because it's very fun and gives them
depth to the game so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you next video